welcome to this video a new video en the
opening challenge series against
anti-roll Jang can't don't know no name
right okay mm ali Knight to d7 hmm okay
playing c3 so that i can actually secure
the bishop 1c to the more aggressive way
to do this is I think with d 4 24 but
nothing I really know so we got some
queenside development but I will play
default soonish message here ok so I'm
going to play for the d5 square this is
something that I had earlier in the game
but i like it it's in it's an easy way
to play and something that I feel like I
handle quite ok so let's see cut one to
the Nitro to get to d5 if possible I
wonder if a form isn't idea here maybe
yeah maybe a fall I'm my development is
quite ok the night is back oh he's just
giving away upon them hmm ok the eye is
counter-attacking only form I seem ok
probably ok if I'm the would have taken
b5 he has a four at the end so good
defense came
let f 1g3 something like that idea yeah
just as in the other game I think he's
okay I had this Bishop it's always
coming to see 5 yeah yeah yeah that's
true yeah I'm not handling this too well
and if I go age 39 h 5 is going to
happen so the way I'm playing this is
not good gym and in the earlier game
also didn't really have any advantage
and maybe before him
he takes it on pass away he doesn't I
came so if five or taking taking at
least them night to a 3 is something I
take them probably not
hmm yeah night a three and I'd be one
night a three would be nice but he might
just play a 5 a-5 is a move that I'm
concerned about I could just play not
sure about it I would consider a 5 here
breaking up the queenside the night be
one was just very slow yep I have to do
this now not comfortable but no choice
hmm
I'm not sure about that so it's really
this is very aggressive but it might
easily backfire on him
so a Bab ruka 8 and I don't see why I
shouldn't just take at five and some
tape here and if I take a five now what
is he doing push it a 3 queena 3 is
leading nowhere I can take twice on f2
maybe that's the only thing that is
worrying me now you might glad night BTW
2f not sure that's a bad passive if i
take night f2 Luke f2 Bishop F to don't
I don't see it I really don't see the
point so I'm taking e for Bishop b4
rookie a desperately five
that I really don't know I played this
badly of course but f5 is probably too
much if I get in 92 Bishop before Bishop
before immediately I should be in good
shape
yeah probably my bad play provoked him
into such drastic measures but maybe
actually II for Bishop before rook e8 we
should be 48 net this should be 5 check
and then look a king at eight as
possible King f8 but I have twin d 1 and
group d 8 okay there should be 48 night
BTW to take sticks okay 55 chick king of
eight bishop e6 bishop f3 star
fortunately winning and so i have to do
this
time warning and now I can chicken go
check it should be six maybe you can
take one if neck cannot take on f5
no time they're hooked it to Queen d2 is
fine 9f to where you can take them no
probably can retreat I'm just retreat
and I don't see a movie a few retreats
the night chair cannot easily move maybe
g3 really pushing him better now that
you can take nonsense and campy it's
really just going back
ah tough till immensely tough to play
it's probably not the best but I have to
play move quickly sure taken at five now
I should have taken at five ah stupid no
I'm in this bloody self pinned down now
take first would have been much better
check we have things to check them check
now I'm far too slow yeah nonsense your
position is just was just winning 54
check check ah cuz I draw at least who
game draw at least I gotta draw out of
this wow that was so difficult to defend
here so f 5 is I don't know we know what
it is it is winning in fact here and
five it is winning what is this so I'm
here at five no it's not winning okay I
took them and takes tags and that took
so a former procreate computers
completely agreeing 92 and now Bishop
takes Knight takes Queen Air Force
winning
okay there is some logic here right if I
move this night my queen Hanks I cannot
move this night because H to Hanks and
if I was attacked if I go look you one
check BAM again winning so that was the
win for him but he went there check now
I got the bishop to this to to them okay
engine gives age 3 as a as the moon
which I played night back it gives night
h2s the best move what is this is crazy
it would have been totally putting me
off but yo creo que rookie one is
probably something I will find it was
attacked so well okay check this is this
something like this is of course at
least the draug of like his two pawns
down but he's so active rookie fireman
okay it's even tricky for him but yeah
I'm I should be okay rook rook e1 would
have been stronger i am rook e1 would
have been stronger okay but I went here
and now yeah okay i forgot i really i
should have taken at five here and is
this I can continue or a brookie one
this is a normal position he has great
compensation but I think I'm sure I
should be okay comp give slight edge
here we should have a draw somehow but
it's time scrambled to two nonsense at
the end okay I'm glad to to having
gotten to draw down okay thanks for
watching